une enseignante m'a dit un jour que j'étais la
maîtresse de la réinvention de soi c'est comme
avoir un secret personne mais moi sait que je le fais
je l'ai vue je l'ai vue du train elle
était elle était avec cet homme
juste une seconde quelque part loin
est-ce  elle à une femme alors pouvez-vous
me dire où vous étiez vendredi soir j'étais
en ville et ensuite je suis allé rendre visite à mon
mari vous voulez dire votre ex-
mari j'ai cru comprendre que la femme qui
a disparu
qui est sa nounou Rachel j'ai besoin  vous de
rester à l'écart alors qu'avez-vous fait pendant
ces heures la nuit Je ne me souviens pas
que c'était un certain temps Missy
ce qui s'est passé cette nuit-là Je ne sais pas
dites-moi la vérité vous avez été vu dans la
région cette nuit
-là avez-vous assassiné Megan Hipwell Non
Je ne suis plus la fille que j'étais,
pourquoi es-tu ici
parce que j'ai peur de moi
toi